we begin in Turkey where the two leading
candidates have cast their ballots in
the most closely contested presidential
election in living memory after 20 years
in power president Richard erdogan is
facing his toughest electoral challenge
yet much of the opposition has United to
back one candidate Kamal kalishirolu in
a country still scarred by February's
devastating earthquakes the government's
Disaster Response is a major issue in
this election the economy is another big
concern after a year that saw inflation
hit 85 percent
in a moment we'll speak to results that
are in Turkey's capital Ankara where the
main opposition leader voted but first
let's go to cinema
you are where president erdogan casts
his ballot Just a short while ago
[Music]
they just cast their ballots in the
school right behind me and right now
president erdon is exiting the school he
is leaving this area and he's expected
to continue to follow the election
results and the uh how the election is
going from our parties Istanbul District
building there is a crowd behind me when
President erdogan entered the building
they started and cheering showing
support and love for president I must
admit that despite that it is the most
challenging election ever for erdon who
has been in the politics for the last
three decades he still has a strong
support strong base in Istanbul where he
started his political career president
erdogan is accused of high inflation
Rising costs of living and limiting
restricting freedom and media in the
country on the other hand he accuses the
opposition and the opposition leader of
collaborating with the adult Kurdistan
Workers Party campaign that was his main
rhetoric
accusing a decision however despite that
erdogan has been losing ground
especially since the ruling up party
lost Istanbul municipality seat to the
opposition
imamolo he is the current mayor still
there is a strong support and president
Ardon actually vows to win in his
Istanbul as it is the largest city in
the country and as a mayoral election is
coming up less than one year ahead in
2024 president erdon totally focused on
his campaign efforts in Istanbul for the
last two days he said when he spoke just
after casting his ballot inside the
inside the school he said that so far
the election was going fine everything
was peaceful and he had the brief from
the interior Minister but of course it's
a long day and everybody is excited
about the outcome from the ballot boxes
Foley I see him we're watching live
pictures right now of President erdogan
surrounded by his supporters after
casting his vote in that school in
Istanbul the neighborhood where he lives
I understand the president and the first
lady casting the ballot Just a short
while ago Istanbul of course is a
stronghold of President erdogan and the
ACT party right his name
definitely definitely this is where he
started his career because in late 1990s
president erdogan was elected as
Istanbul mayor he was in the seat for
about two years and then he was present
back then
the secularist administration uh when
when they when they put him in prison
many were saying that he would be coming
back to Politics as Nelson Mandela
however the the the then current
government said he couldn't even be a
local head in any neighborhood but then
he became a prime minister and then he
became the president he chained he
switched turkey's parliamentary
administrative Administration system to
presidential system and it's been more
than two decades but of course for
president erdon being successful in
Istanbul is probably the most important
thing as Istanbul constitutes nearly 20
percent of the whole population most of
the
electrode is here the universities are
here businesses here all the taxes half
of the tax revenue half of the
industrial industrial output is coming
out from Istanbul and of course no need
to explain that it stopped despite
Ankara is the capital Istanbul is the
gate for turkey opening to The Globe
that's why winning here is very
important and winning even the
municipality of Istanbul is very
important as in Turkey municipalities
generate income for political parties
because Governors are appointed but a
municipality Mayors are elected they are
candidates of political parties that's
why Istanbul is very critical for
erdogan and during the last week he
always mentioned that if Istanbul says
yes his political party and himself are
possibly going to win Folly okay cinim
thank you very much for bringing us the
latest there from Istanbul where again
president erdogan has just cast his
ballot
at his neighborhood in Istanbul at a
school there he is currently greeting
his supporters a lot of them as you can
see have come out to show their support
for the incumbent who is running for a
third consecutive term Let's cross over
now to Resource sadar who's in Ankara
Turkey is capital where the opposition
made opposition's main candidate wrestle
has also cast his vote
that's correct you are in a primary
school in Ankara where the opposition
leader Kemal khalstaro the main leader
of the opposition came out Crystal has
just casted his his Ward so people his
supporters were here waiting for him
since morning and once he got into the
schools so we have seen that they were
warmly welcoming him that was quite an
excitement here and the hopes are very
very high this time because they believe
they can defeat president erdogan this
time so um six opposition parties have
came together and they have formed an
alliance speaking
as their Unity candidate and through his
presidential election campaign he has
been accusing the government of the
corruption Vanishing the democracy and
peace and also destroying turkey's
repetition internationally that's why he
was promising his supporters or the
Turks the public hear that once he's in
the power he's going to restore
democracy and peace at home he's going
to give great teacher will create
conditions for the greater individual
freedoms and rights in in turkey and
also internationally he was promising
better relations with the West to boost
the ties with the West with the United
States European Union NATO and also in
the last two days of the campaign he has
been warned in Russia that it is
meddling with Turkish Internal Affairs
which was regarded as a signal to the
West that once he's in power the
relations of turkey and Russia are going
to be more nuanced so but here one of
the main factors that is going to
determine the outcome of the election is
definitely the economy so the
skyrocketing prices here and people are
suffering from Bad prices and also one
of the highest inflation rates in the
world so
the under position was very much
focusing on that at the economy recovery
in economy is going to be on the top of
their agenda once they are the
government however today hey so it's the
first run round of the election if none
of the candidates receive more than 50
percent plus one would then is going to
be decided in the second round which is
going to be held on 20 May 28th of May
thank you thank you Russell for that
resources live for us there in Ankara as
the result mentioned the economy is a
major concern for voters earthquake
reconstruction is another concern almost
100 days after the devastating Tremors
in southern turkey hundreds of thousands
of survivors are still living in camps
or are scattered around the country a
zener had a reports from antakia that's
not stopping them from voting
these people traveled for hours to
return to their home provinces to vote
survivors of February's earthquakes they
were displaced more than a million
people relocated to cities across the
country according to Turkish law you
need to be at your place of residence in
order to cast The Ballot if you do not
re-register a new address people here
say they are determined to make their
voices heard
I came here for voting to change this
government because when the earthquake
happened
this government didn't came for three
days that's why I want to change this
government
the selection will help us to to select
our future if our future is good or not
we will see you today
and Quake hit Southern provinces
thousands and thousands of buildings
either collapsed or are just
uninhabitable so authorities have to set
up makeshift polling stations using
these container cabins in order for the
election to take place and as you can
see a voter turnout is is quite High
people here
on the back of their minds when they
make the decision it is about who is the
person they have faith in to rebuild
their lives people here have not just
lost their homes they've lost their
livelihoods they've lost everything
this is our house it is heavily damaged
and we believe our president will finish
building our homes within a year we are
expecting him to support us he have
supported him for years
the president erdogan and his ruling
party still
port in these areas he can still rely on
his
they believe him when he says hundreds
of thousands of homes are going to be
rebuilt within a year those in the
opposition they disagree they blame the
government for mishandling the disaster
and for the lacks policies the lack of
proper oversight that allowed
thousands and thousands of buildings to
collapse
al-jazeera Southern turkey